Ladies, have you ever felt tired, easily frustrated,
and prone to feeling low?
Maybe it’s just your birth control.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
The pill is over 60 years old!
It was a revolution, it allowed women to take
full control of their reproductive health.
And since then, it’s been studied a whole
bunch, and we’ve talked about it before
on the show.
Check some links for those episodes down below.
Some women suffer from a form of PMS so severe
it affects work, family, life, etc, called
PreMenstrual Dysphoric Disorder or PMDD.
For some of these women a prescription of
birth control makes symptoms easier to manage.
On the other hand, birth control gets a bad
rap.
While many women report no adverse side effects,
some say the pill makes them MORE moody and
depressed.
So who is right?
Well, a recent study published in the Journal
of Human Brain Mapping found that oral birth
control has a strange way of affect a woman’s
brain.
Neuroscientists from UCLA compared some women
who take oral contraceptives, or OC, and some
“naturally-cycling” women who don’t.
They found that women who take OC had lower
cortical thickness in the lateral orbitofrontal
cortex and the posterior cingulate cortex.
The researchers say that these parts of the
brain are related to processing rewards and
other things like incoming stimuli.
But more research is needed to see if these
changes are related to a change in behavior.
Although, the lead author of that study told
the Huffington Post that those changes in
the brain might be responsible for some of
the negative feelings some women get when
starting the pill, like anxiety and depression.
But these results are a stark contrast to
some found in a 2010 study.
That study published in the journal Brain
Research also compared women on the pill and
“naturally-cycling” women.
The researchers found that some women on birth
control had more grey matter in some areas
of the brain responsible for emotional regulation,
memory and learning.
You’d think that would make women less moody,
right?
What’s going on?
One review published in the journal Frontiers
of Neuroscience, found that there are at least
two groups of women who respond differently
to birth control pills.
Some really do seem to be more emotionally
stable on the pill while others have increased
rates of depression, anxiety, fatigue, neurotic
symptoms, compulsion and anger.
The researchers found that in some studies
elevated levels of estradiol, a derivative
of which is a major component in OC,
might have antidepressant properties.
But they also found that it can lower the
body’s production of estradiol, which might
lower moods.
That same review also found that progesterone
-- the other major component of combination
OC -- might elevate moods at low concentrations
but maybe lower moods at higher concentrations.
It really depends on what kind of birth control
you’re on and what levels of hormones those
pills contain.
One meta-analysis published in the Journal
of Affective Disorders found that for most
women, OC affect on mood is a positive one.
Yet there is a sub-group who may experience
the opposite.
So while birth control does allow women to
take control over their reproductive choices,
it’s also a very personal decision and seems
the effects are personal too.
In fact, the pill can even affect who you
fancy too.
Check out this video from Trace and Amy to
learn more.